este lunes el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken aterrizó
en Jerusalén con un mensaje fomentar la
resolución de las tensiones entre Israel
y Palestina y alcanzar el proyecto de
paz estancado desde 2014 a través de la
creación de los dos estados
palestinos e israelíes disfrutan de las
mismas medidas libertad seguridad
oportunidades justicia y dignidad el
presidente biden sigue plenamente
comprometido con ese objetivo seguimos
creyendo que la mejor manera de lograrlo
es preservar y hacer realidad la visión
de dos estados
pero muchos consideran que las
condiciones entre israelíes y pales
están lejos de ser iguales sobre todo
tras las últimas redadas israelíes en
fisjordania con más de una decena de
muertos y que Estados Unidos está
claramente posicionado con Israel Aliado
histórico ya que blinken solo dio
condolencias a las víctimas israelíes se
limitó a llamar a una desescalada de la
violencia y a recordar la solución de
los dos estados algo que el Primer
Ministro israelí segundo
tenemos la intención de profundizar la
paz que ya hemos hecho en los acuerdos
de Abraham discutimos algunas medidas
que estamos considerando juntos
no obstante Israel está aplicando
medidas colectivas contra los palestinos
así como la presencia de los colonos en
sus territorios Más allá del tema de
Palestina blinken y netanyahu también
discutieron otros puntos a fundamentales
en sus relaciones la fortaleza de la
alianza entre Estados Unidos e Israel
Los acuerdos de Israel con naciones
Árabes y la importancia de evitar el
desarrollo nuclear de Irán Este es el
cuarto viaje de blinken a la región y se
espera que el martes se reúna con el
presidente palestino mahmud abad en
ramala